il s'appelle Ganga et Romain et Marc et
nous venons de suivre leur exigeant
parcours pour intégrer la Légion
étrangère grâce à ce documentaire
réalisé par Damien muratel de quoi
vouloir maintenant savoir plus sur cette
troupe militaire qui n'aurait semble à
aucune autre et c'est ce que nous allons
faire maintenant avec nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec vous pour commencer Jean-Michel
Houssin bienvenue
38 années de services dont 23 passer à
l'étranger vous êtes aujourd'hui
retraités responsable de la mémoire
légionnaire de la Fédération des
Sociétés d'anciens de la Légion
étrangère votre dernier livre s'intitule
sous-officier de la Légion étrangère de
1831 à nos jours et c'est un ouvrage de
publier aux éditions d'un autre ailleurs
Étienne de Monteil est également avec
nous bienvenue bonjour vous êtes
journaliste romancier et directeur du
Figaro littéraire depuis maintenant 2006
votre le dernier roman s'intitule La
douceur il est disponible chez Stock
nous citrons aussi en lien cette fois
avec cette émission consacrée à la
Légion étrangère des hommes irréguliers
paru chez Perrin il y a peu de temps
vous êtes également première classe
d'honneur de la Légion étrangère en
effet expliquez-nous
étrangère
honorifique mais qui nous honore que la
Légion réserve à ses amis avocats hommes
politiques journalistes qui ont eu
l'occasion un titre ou un autre d'aider
l'institution et c'est une manière pour
la Légion de remercier puis de
constituer une sorte de de groupe
d'amitié de solidarité autour de tout ce
qu'elle fait pour ces légionnaires ou
pour ses anciens légionnaires Pierre
Julien est enfin avec nous bienvenue
bonjour vous êtes journaliste ancien
rédacteur en chef adjoint chez RTL et
spécialisé dans le domaine de la défense
vous n'êtes pas je
de première classe d'honneur de la
Légion étrangère je le précise alors je
suis colonel de réserve mais citoyenne
de l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace
Jean-Michel Houssin après ce film que
nous venons de voir on s'interroge
évidemment sur le mode de recrutement de
sélection pour la Légion étrangère et du
16 si ça pose un certain nombre de
questions est-ce qu'il a changé ce
modèle de recrutement et de sélection
depuis 1980 c'est l'année où vous aviez
20 ans et vous êtes engagé dans la
région il a changé non pas
fondamentalement les les tests sont
quasi équivalents avec des curseurs un
petit peu différents en fonction des
desiderata des chefs mais
les tests sont les mêmes ils ont été
modifiés par nécessité comme par exemple
de têtes psychotechnique est un nouveau
test qui a été spécialement créé par
l'armée de l'air pour nous mais ça reste
sur la même base Jean-Michel Houssin
c'est c'est pas le nom sous lequel vous
avez intégré la Légion étrangère
de s'intègre pas sous son vrai nom dans
la légion étagère du moins les premières
années alors ça a tout dépend
les Français c'est obligatoire de
changer de nom la Légion étrangère est
une troupe d'étrangers sous
commandements français donc de fait le
français quand ils s'engage on lui
change la sincérité parce que la loi ne
le permet pas de l'engager voilà après
tout dépend encore une fois les
désiderata de du général Condor région
étrangère il y a eu dans moi dans les
périodes que j'ai connues sur mes 38
années de service des périodes où on
engageait les gens avec leur véritable
nom avec leur vieillitam nationalité et
d'autres non aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas
français vous êtes engagé sous quel nom
vous et avec quelle nationalité Robert
canadien et je regrette j'ai pas vu le
Canada voilà mais c'est comme ça il faut
assumer voilà j'étais canadien pendant 8
ans voilà alors on embauche et on engage
après avoir passé bien sûr les
sélections et si on est passé ce cap
est-ce qu'on engage tout le monde sous
la Légion étrangère c'est ce qui se dit
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas cette
troupe militaire
on a l'impression que tout le monde peut
s'engager dans les étrangères y compris
pour ceux qui ont commis des méfaits
dans leur vie antérieure on va dire
est-ce que c'est vraiment le cas tout le
monde peut lever le doigt pour postuler
voilà après il y a un tri bien
évidemment
pour parler de voilà des choses
mythiques ce qu'on commis des méfaits la
Légion étrangère comme toute institution
n'a aucun intérêt à intégrer dans ces
rangs des gens qui ont commis des fait
trop graves des criminels de trafic de
diogues des pédophiles des choses comme
ça c'est des gens qui un jour ou l'autre
vont reproduire et on a encore une
capacité à trier même aujourd'hui donc
il y a un premier tri dans les éventuels
condamnations
tout le monde est passé au crible de
notre division sécurité et c'est elle
est très bien informée dans le monde
entier je parle je parle pas des années
anciennes je veux dire à l'entrée par de
l'Indochine quand on était 50000
peut-être qu'il y en a qui sont passés
au travers des mailles du filet au jour
d'aujourd'hui tout le monde est rattrapé
voilà donc ça non et après c'est les
tests de sélection voilà on va revoir
les trois légionnaires puisqu'ils ont
été intégrés qu'on a découvert dans ce
film et j'en parle avec vous juste après
je m'appelle Romain Antoine j'ai 20 ans
mon père a fait 18 ans dans les Forces
Spéciales à l'armée de terre ce qui m'a
plu en premier c'est la Légion étrangère
et pas l'armée de terre
vous voyez le cadeau Marc cette
américain alors je ne sais pas si ils
sont vrais prénoms c'est possible quoi
qu'il en soit au cours de ce
documentaire il a quitté lui la Légion
étrangère après avoir sans doute c'est
ce qu'on comprend dans ce film avoir eu
un passé difficile de l'autre côté de de
l'Atlantique qu'est-ce qui vous fascine
vous le plus vous qui n'avez pas été
légionnaire
dans cette fameuse troupe militaire
troupe militaire d'élite s'il en est on
va y revenir tout à l'heure qu'est-ce
qui vous fascine le plus d'où elle vous
vient cette fascination parce que je
suis romancier j'ai l'esprit romanesque
et c'est une troupe qui est romanesque
il faut pas trop l'idéaliser mais sur le
plan des histoires et des destins
individuels c'est un endroit
à nulle part égal vraiment chaque
légionnaire chaque ancien légionnaire a
une histoire particulière une histoire
qui est souvent cachée ou du moins qui
est resté secrète parce que la Légion
respecte elle connaît mais elle respecte
le passé de ces hommes et tous les
légionnaires que j'ai rencontrés qui
soient français c'est-à-dire canadien ou
belge qui viennent à dire Jean-Michel ou
venant de très très loin chacun une
histoire c'est aussi ce sont des destins
de rupture venir à la Légion c'est
rompre avec un pays parfois avec une
famille avec une rupture c'est ce qu'on
lit toujours du travail sur ce dossier
c'est quelque chose de très romanes
parce que la Légion donne une seconde
chance derrière l'acceptation à la
Légion bien sûr il y a ces questions
judiciaires parfois mais surtout on te
donne une deuxième chance et un
délinquant si la Légion estime que le
candidat en vaut la peine elle va lui
donner une deuxième chance le képi blanc
c'est le képi de la pureté retrouvée en
quelque sorte cette deuxième chance elle
peut être trahie dans ce cas-là la
sanction est forte mais elle peut la
deuxième chance peut-être donner et
donner aux légionnaires une deuxième vie
à la légion et une deuxième vie après la
Légion est-ce que vous y voyez aussi un
modèle d'intégration parce qu'il y a
tout de même plus de 140 nationalités
qui se côt à l'intérieur de de ce corps
de l'armée de terre et vous l'avez dit
les jeunère ils servent tous sous
contrat à titre étranger et sont
commandés par des officiers et officiers
français alors modèle oui parce que il y
a une méthode on apprend le front le
français je voyais les jeunes les jeunes
légionnaires et qui s'exprimaient en
anglais très vite avec la méthode dite
Kepi blanc ils vont vraiment apprendre
le français pour comprendre ce que c'est
que c'est une méthode qui est plus blanc
parce que je crois que il s'agit de 500
mots en français voilà pour apprendre
qui permettent de comprendre les ordres
voilà qui permettent de comprendre et
puis un jour d'en donner soi-même et
puis de s'intégrer peu à peu à devenir
quelqu'un qui vit en France aussi donc
modèle oui parce que ça donne des des
jeunes gens qui peuvent évoluer dans la
société française comme le jour ils sont
en permission le jour où etc modèle non
parce que ils sont évidemment
volontaires et que tout
toute personne qui va sonner à la porte
de du territoire français n'a pas la
vocation pas la capacité l'envie de
servir dans l'armée française et dans la
légion étrangers en particulier donc
c'est quand même sur la base du
volontariat et de la contrainte le
légionnaire est un bon soldat parce
qu'il rentre dans ce moule mais la
limite c'est que tout le monde n'est pas
fait pour passer par ce moule alors pour
information il y aurait environ 34 %
d'occidentaux à la Légion 28% de cela
environ 12 pour 12%
d'Africains 13% d'asiatiques et 13%
viennent d'Amérique latine
90% des légionnaires aujourd'hui sont
d'origine étrangère Pierre Julien vous
voyez tout de suite rajouter quelque
chose oui justement c'est vous parliez
des 140 150 nationalités pour 9000
légionnaires c'est-à-dire si vous voyez
s'il faut comparer avec les 130 000
dollars de terre mais là où
effectivement vous avez totalement
raison c'est-à-dire que ce phénomène
d'osmo cette semaine de cohésion surtout
pour les légionnaires c'est ce qui
détermine alors vous me direz que
peut-être dans toutes les armées c'est
un peu ça mais il y a une véritable
cohésion c'est le fameux Lego Patriat
nostra c'est-à-dire à travers cet
institution on devient un véritable
camarade camarade de combat Kama frère
d'armes vous apprenez le français qui va
être votre langue commune ces 400 mots
qui vont permettre effectivement de bien
comprendre les ordres parce qu'il n'est
pas question effectivement qu'en pleine
opération vous ayez un légionnaire qui
qui perdent simplement le sens de la
phrase il peut risquer sa vie et surtout
la vie de ses camarades hors-sait même
camarades sur lequel il va s'appuyer
c'est avec eux d'ailleurs qu'il va aussi
apprendre le français il y a tout ça on
le voit très bien d'ailleurs c'est ça
même si effectivement on a l'impression
que pour rentrer dans la Légion
étrangère c'est pas très dur selon le
document on voit il faut quand même être
sportif il faut savoir nager il faut
savoir courir il faut être endurant mais
on a l'impression que ce n'est pas le
faire les plus importants les critères
les plus importants sont peut-être aussi
liés à l'esprit et à l'état d'esprit
pour entrer dans la légion c'est
l'esprit c'est la cohésion le corps
avant tout avant l'individu lui-même je
me suis lancé
vous avez dit tout à l'heure les
sous-officiers uniquement les officiers
voilà les sous-officiers sont tous à
titre étrangers voilà à part les cadres
blancs mais on sait pas forcément le
sujet mais c'est une prémunité et dans
les officiers il y a à peu près 10% qui
sont à titre étranger donc des gens qui
ont commencé leur carrière comme simple
légionnaires je me suis laissé dire tout
de même la Légion va un problème elle ne
recruter plus assez de légionnaire
d'origine française et ça pouvait poser
un problème justement dans le processus
tout à fait intégration c'est un
problème j'irai qui qui dure au fil du
temps c'est toujours c'est quasiment
l'existence du groupement de recrutement
la région étrangère donc un régiment
spécialisé là-dedans et toutes ces
actions qui mènent en France sont
vraiment dirigées sur le français bien
sûr quelqu'un d'autre va se présenter on
va s'en occuper mais le Français est le
plus difficile à atteindre pourquoi
parce que déjà tous nos camarades des
autres armées sont très attractifs
on les paye pas mieux que les autres on
leur promet un peu plus de sueur etc
c'est pas forcément ce qu'on a envie
d'entendre le jeune Français au jour
d'aujourd'hui et nous on a un besoin
vital de français ou de francophones
pour permettre la culturation de tous
ces étrangers sinon ça ne fonctionnerait
pas donc il y a des ratios voilà l'idéal
c'est d'avoir entre 20 et 25% plus on en
a mieux c'est parce que ça facilite
l'intégration mais il faut pas descendre
en dessous actuellement c'est un peu
compliqué voilà et vous évoquez le
salaire d'un légionnaire vous pouvez
nous donner le salaire de base le
salaire de base
un simple légionnaire tout tous nos nous
on est intégré à l'AR donc on est payé
administré et gérer exactement de la
même façon on va parler des terrains
d'opération ce pourquoi on destine cette
troupe d'élite vous êtes d'accord avec
cette appellation trouve des Lite
lorsqu'il est question de Légion
étrangère bien sûr c'est une troupe
d'élite alors la question de savoir
finalement est-ce qu'on les utilise
souvent et beaucoup pour les bases parce
que lorsqu'on garde l'histoire de la
Légion étrangère il y a quand même
évidemment des moments historiques dans
l'histoire de notre pays
la colonisation on a beaucoup utilisé
les légionnaires pour coloniser à la
fois l'Afrique du Nord l'Afrique
subsaharienne notamment pas seulement la
décolonisation la guerre d'Indochine il
y a eu beaucoup de légionnaires qui sont
morts à l'occasion de cette terre et
bien sûr la guerre d'Algérie est-ce
qu'on pourrait dire que les légionnaires
sont souvent utilisés pour remplir les
bases
pour remplir les missions que les autres
ne veulent pas
devrait être discuté
aux ordres de la République française du
pouvoir politique on a fait des beaucoup
de reproches à la Légion je pense à
l'histoire du premier être engagé dans
le pouce d'Alger
la Légion étrangère servait
sous la quatrième et la Cinquième
République et obéissait aux ordres du
ministre de la Défense donc il est
possible qu'il y a eu une tentation du
monde politique du personnel politique
de solliciter des légionnaires comme
effectivement exécuteur de leur
politique de leur politique et les
légionnaires ont obéi et ça ça a donné
lieu effectivement à des drames humains
comme par exemple le premier EP
historiquement en plus du temps de le
Louis-Philippe 1831 vous en parliez
c'est lui
qui crée la Légion étrangère des
étrangers pourquoi les étrangers parce
qu'on peut les envoyer plus facilement
combattre sur les théâtres les plus durs
que des vrais Français j'allais dire que
des Français que le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge chantant la Marseillaise là c'est
effectivement différent
aujourd'hui la Légion étrangère est
envoyée j'allais dire un peu comme
Napoléon lorsqu'il envoyait sa garde que
ce soit la vieille gare tout à la fin
pour gagner la bataille on peut dire que
la Légion est envoyée pour gagner la
première bataille elle est envoyée en
premier le plus souvent c'est elle qui
ouvre le bal on va dire pour parce
qu'elle a cette force elle a aussi ce
côté que l'adversaire finalement retient
c'est-à-dire la Légion arrive ou la
Légion saute comme sur colvezi en 1978
ou sur des ou sur ton boom tout il n'y a
pas si longtemps en 2013 dans le cadre
de l'opération Serval
l'adversaire l'ennemi le terrain le
djihadiste et autres c'est qu'en face de
lui il y a la Légion étrangère
psychologiquement
c'est un élément important la Légion est
là on ne sait jamais elle peut renverser
les choses et à partir de là il va
falloir se préparer peut-être même à la
défaite je la Légion étrangère en
première ligne allez-y recontexcuser un
petit peu les propos
donc au travers de mes mes deux études
menées pour écrire les deux livres je me
suis aperçu à ma grande surprise parce
que on dit même si on vit dans une
institution des fois on découvre plein
de choses par exemple à la création de
la Légion donc tout ça était né de débat
parlementaire et ça répondait à un
double objectif
traiter un problème de sécurité publique
avec beaucoup de d'immigrés d'étrangers
d'anciennes troupes utilisés qui
traînaient sur le territoire national et
qui était pas forcément donc ça les gens
le savent pas et en même temps commencer
à regarder de l'autre côté de la
meilleure année il y avait des terres à
acquérir et donc il fallait quelqu'un
pour aller là-bas et ce faisant ils ont
décidé de créer la légion
dans les statuts elle ne devait jamais
être sur le territoire national au
départ donc stationner à l'étranger et
ne devait pas venir sur le territoire
national bon après par la force des
choses ça a été changé et il y a des
débats très clairs ou des éminents
personnages de l'époque qui disent voilà
en envoyant un déjeuner en économise
trois Français un soldat un qu'on envoie
à l'étranger etc et puis en plus on va
le payer moins donc ça sera bien après
base je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
avec Monsieur voilà c'est pas les bases
on répond on fait d'abord le produit
professionnelment possible et on
respecte en tout cas et c'était la
question que je vous posais c'est-à-dire
des opérations qu'on ne va pas confier à
d'autres régiments à d'autres troupes
militaires parce que elles sont
peut-être risquées il y a peut-être
voilà et qu'on préfère y envoyer la
Légion d'aujourd'hui on est dans un tour
bien comprendre ça
vous y avez les idées
morts en Indochine
sur 36000 à peu près d'effectifs on est
monté jusqu'à près de 50 000 mais
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait un afflu
notamment d'allemand énorme à cette
époque là donc pour la France j'irai en
situation de guerre je comprends que ça
soit du pain béni on a des soldats en
plus qui était déjà guéris Hop qui
veulent s'engager la Légion était
capable c'est un peu comme aujourd'hui
on maintient un effort de recrutement à
1600 les dernières infos que j'ai c'est
ça pourquoi parce que l'armée de terre a
du mal à recruter et nous on a encore
cette capacité à trier voilà autrement
dit on a de Chine et avec le nombre de
morts que vous avez cité on avait
beaucoup engagé des anciens de la
wehrmarque en réalité qui ont nourri les
rangs de la Légion étrangère à cette
époque vous avez fait combien
d'opérations extérieures avec la Légion
étrangère suite ou 19 opérations mission
MCD voilà tout confondu alors pour
l'essentiel c'était quoi ces missions
est-ce que vous étiez en première ligne
que la dupierre Julien
spécialité donc j'étais en première
ligne votre tout ma carrière parce que
j'étais en unité de combat comme tout le
monde au début mais après bon mes
aptitudes techniques civils m'ont
rattrapé et on m'a mis on m'a versé dans
le domaine qu'on appelle la maintenance
la réparation donc j'étais même en unité
de combat j'ai fait 28 ans en deuxième
Rui au deuxième régiment étranger
d'infantique et un régiment d'infanterie
numérisé j'étais pas sur la première
ligne j'étais avec la compagnie de
soutien juste derrière mais on
participait à toutes les opérations donc
la force combattante aussi force de
renseignement j'imagine quand on est les
premiers sur les lieux ça permet de
renseigner tous les autres voix doit
être analysés enfin pas interpréter
analyser et retransmis
la professionnalisation de l'armée un
petit peu relativisé même si la Légion
garde sa spécificité et son prestige
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'unités de l'armée
française régulière comme on dit les
troupes de marine notamment
on se professionnalise on cette
expérience et sont envoyés en mission au
même titre que la légion dans ce que
vous avez appelé effectivement le
mouvement tournant des engagements
en Afrique par exemple et ça d'une
certaine façon un petit peu changé ce
côté un mouvement à 4 temps on le voit
au Sahel ou effectivement il y avait des
changements réguliers de troupes où en
Afghanistan lorsqu'il y a eu l'embuscade
monstrueuse 12 bines ou le 8e RPIMa donc
régiment de parachutistes d'infanterie
de marine a perdu 10 hommes
il a été remplacé par des chasseurs
alpins puis la Légion étrangère est
arrivée ce sont là effectivement vous
avez totalement raison le
professionnelisme des armées a modifié
la donne 95 le processus là évidemment
Jacques Chirac voilà avec donc l'abandon
de enfin la suspension du service natal
c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas totalement
supprimé mais là aussi c'est ce qui a
amené aussi des
jeunes hommes à rejoindre la Légion
étrangère aussi là-dessus qu'on le
veuille ou non et ça se vaut tous les
deux vous avez totalement raison il y a
cette esprit de corps et cet esprit de
corps finalement va permettre à des
jeunes on a peut-être pas assez parlé de
cette seconde chance qui leur est donnée
ça a été dit
il a toujours été comme ça
c'est ce que je voulais dire va se
traduire sur le terrain va se traduire
sur le terrain vous avez finalement en
partie réussi votre vie parce que ce qui
vous avait été refusé quand vous étiez
jeune parce que vous en effet allez des
conneries avant le témoignage de
l'américain le dit bien et bien là vous
avez une un côté positif de votre action
votre vie ce n'est pas celle d'un gamin
abandonné c'est un gamin entouré et un
gamin qui réussit finalement dans sa
mission parce que pour tout militaire et
en particulier pour en particulier pour
un légionnaire réussir sa mission c'est
c'est cette vocation oui cette deuxième
chance ou c'est quelque chose de très
important aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la
transparence est demandée partout elle a
de très bons côtés mais elle a quelque
chose de très accablant et effectivement
moi j'aime beaucoup à la Légion l'idée
qu'on puisse véritablement redonner une
seconde chance par l'anonymat ça peut
être choquant pour le grand public mais
par l'anonymat par le respect de la
personne de ce qui a été son passé mais
aussi de ce que doit être son avenir et
bien la personne se relance dans la vie
et aujourd'hui je connais peu
d'institutions et même la justice a du
mal à faire valoir la deuxième chance le
monde médiatique j'en fais partie je le
sais poursuit les gens bien longtemps
après leur condamnation et on lira sur
les réseaux sociaux sur les sites dans
les journaux il a fait si il a fait ça à
la Légion tout d'un coup les choses
s'interrompent et la personne
véritablement revit sous une autre
identité nouvelle histoire c'est assez
rare ça peut être très surprenant mais
je trouve sur le plan humain que c'est
quelque chose de magnifique et qui doit
être protégé quelle est la mission dont
vous êtes le plus cher celle que vous
avez encore en mémoire parce qu'il
fallait des capacités physiques
extrêmes parce que la mission était
particulièrement dangereuse ou parce
qu'elle revêtait un enjeu prioritaire il
y en a une qui sort du lot parmi celle
que vous avez
et pour lesquels il y a peut-être
prescription et pour lesquelles et dont
vous pouvez nous parler aujourd'hui tout
avec les bons mots mais je veux dire je
les analyse pas comme ça on est très
pragmatique nous et on se concentre sur
ce qu'on a à faire et nos camarades
la mission peut-être la plus abouti ça a
été l'Afghanistan pourquoi parce que
suite à l'ouzbink qui a évoqué monsieur
il y a eu un effort qui n'avait jamais
été fait avant au niveau des dotations
en matériel des dotations munitions des
équipements et ça a été certainement
pour nous la première fois où on se
sentait en capacité réelle pas nous
physiquement ou techniquement de faire
notre métier mais d'avoir les moyens de
le faire voilà
dans ma carrière j'ai participé à des
opérations au chat ou quoi ou on avait
quand même la plupart de nos chargeurs
qui étaient vides et on était tout seul
face au désert et aux éventuels libyens
qui pouvaient venir à l'époque bon voilà
c'est jamais très satisfaisant autrement
dit un Afghanistan vous avez eu ce
sentiment de travailler dans de bonnes
conditions financières avec le matériel
ça s'est déclenché et maintenant l'armée
française est bien équipée ça coûte très
cher bien évidemment mais voilà c'était
après chaque mission est belle mais pour
des raisons différentes voilà
on voit des choses il fallait en garder
une ça serait peut-être celle-là elle me
dites-vous moi je vais revenir à 1991
les gars du golf alors j'ai pas vécu la
grande chevauchée du Premier Régiment
étranger de cavalerie premier rail que
donc du colonel Ivanov je l'ai pas vécu
justement vous parliez des du
renseignement des crabes donc c'est à
dire c'est commando de recherche en
profondeur d'ailleurs je crois qu'il y a
un ancien crabe qui a à peu près réussi
qui est au deuxième repas qui était au
deuxième main qui s'appelle Thierry
burqa qui est chef d'état-major des
armées maintenant moi j'ai surtout vécu
on va dire la fin de la guerre du Golfe
la dépollution le déminage des plages de
Koweït City avec vous aviez vous avez
raison parce qu'à l'époque c'était le
sixième régiment étranger de génie qui
était tout jeune en tout jeune régiment
qui avait quoi six sept ans d'existence
et le matériel n'était peut-être pas le
plus adapté à cette dépollution mais
c'est légionnaire on fait un travail
extraordinaire avec réuss à déterminer
là où était les bombes les mines
anti-personnelles les mines bondissantes
et ça c'est un souvenir de voir ce
professionnalisme de ces hommes avec
encore peut-être les aiguilles qui
cherchaient comme ça ça marque ça marque
d'autant plus que trois semaines après
un de ses légionsaires a été tué par une
mine qui qui a sauté juste au moment où
il était il essayait de la de la
désamorcer il y avait 700 Ukrainiens
dans la Légion étrangère avant le début
du conflit en Ukraine et c'est vrai le
que le patron de la Légion étrangère le
chef d'état-major c'est un peu inquiété
de voir un certain nombre de désertion
de légionnaires
Ukrainiens justement partir rejoindre
leur pays d'origine pour mener la guerre
contre les Russes en l'occurrence cette
un vrai problème au sein de la Légion
c'est désertion de de légionnaire
ukrainien c'est un problème de toujours
dire ce ne sont que des hommes quand
leur famille sont en danger ou la
batterie parce qu'ils aiment leur patrie
dans le documentaire
je suis haut parle de qu'on chante pas
la Marseillaise il y a une raison
profonde à ça voilà parce que eux ils
aiment leur patrie on la joue mais on ne
la chante pas voilà donc
c'est toujours un danger ça c'est
produit pour les gars Yougoslavie etc le
et là vous avez mis je crois un système
en place alors pour vous qui garantirait
à la Légion
voilà le général commandant la Légion
étrangère a mis en place au début du
conflit en Ukraine une mesure tout à
fait inédite qui a été salué par tout le
monde nous autant nous les anciens que
que les gens d'activent il a permis
à tous les Ukrainiens qui le
souhaitaient de pouvoir se rendre à la
frontière du crâne l'ordre était clair
de ne pas rentrer en Ukraine parce que
sont des soldats français donc ça a des
conséquences politiques énormes
récupérer leur famille et les ramener et
la Légion s'occuperait de leur famille
voilà et donc il y a près de 200
familles qui sont rentrés comme ça par
ce fait il a jugulé les désertions il y
en a eu quelques-unes mais ça il y en
aura toujours et
selon lui j'ai pas les chiffres mais il
faut comprendre que le gars des tiraillé
entre le respect de son contrat il sait
que sa famille est peut-être en danger
bon voilà ça serait ce que des hommes
donc la part bien il leur a permis et de
répondre à tous leurs objectifs
personnels c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait une
petite chose qui est nouvelle c'est que
jadis le légionnaire est vraiment coupé
de sa famille aujourd'hui par le
téléphone par les réseaux sociaux les
légionnaires ils vivent au rythme à la
fois de leur vie quotidienne à la légion
mais aussi rythme de leur pays d'origine
et la première permission elle
intervient je crois qu'au bout d'un an
et demi mais le téléphone mais les
réseaux sociaux mais tous les moyens de
télécommunication font qu'ils vivent
quand même malgré tout en phase avec
leur pays avec l'actualité du pays ils
sont très au courant de tout et c'est
beaucoup plus dur dans ces cas-là
effectivement de vivre ça autrement dit
il y a moins de désertions qu'il y en a
eu dans la région étrangère grâce
justement à ces j'en sais rien la
mentalité je ne sais pas j'ai pas de
chiffre et la mentalité du légionnaire a
beaucoup changé de ce point de vue là
mais j'ai souvenir mon moment de la
Yougoslavie l'armée croate qui était
embryonnaire s'est constitué de quoi
d'excellents sous-officiers ou
légionnaires Croates qui m'est
massivement sont repartis moi je suis
allé en Croatie et le le général que je
saluais était un ancien sergent-chef de
la Légion étrangère et donc il y a eu
beaucoup de gâchis entre guillemets et
c'est très très bien que le général
lardais se soit dit c'est impossible
d'empêcher cette espèce de Vasse
communicant entre ce qui se passe en
[Musique]
depuis quand il a créé son petit
micro-cosse et ce qui s'est passé avec
les Népalais après ça fait un peu c'est
mécanique c'est une pompe voilà elle est
amorcée et donc ça suit voilà les
Népalais c'est très technique l'armée
britannique a fermé le régiment enfin à
sensiblement réduit son ses régiments
burqa donc où ils peuvent aller on est
le seul endroit au monde on peut venir
et les Colombiens on n'a pas vraiment
enfin moi en tout cas j'ai pas vraiment
d'explication parce que il y a pas de
changement notable dans le pays de dans
les dans les cinq disons derrière nous
quoi voilà alors je l'ai dit il y avait
700 légionnaires
Ukrainiens
parmi la Légion étrangère avant le début
du conflit est-ce qu'on peut penser
est-ce que c'est un fait est-ce qu'un
certain nombre de ces légionnaires
rentre sur le territoire
ukrainien pour renseigner
l'armée française et les armées
occidentales sur l'évolution des combats
sur place est-ce que ça c'est une piste
émotionnellement une piste mais dans
l'opérationnel ça existe aujourd'hui des
légionnaires qui sont là pour le
renseignement alors logiquement ce n'est
pas leur travail il y a des unités
spécialisées qui font du on parlait tout
à l'heure de l'ancêtre c'est-à-dire les
fameux crampes aujourd'hui sont les
forces spéciales en réalité donc là on
n'est pas sur le travail dragon
parachuté
ou le deuxième USA qui ont à les faire
des missions derrière les lignes sans
parler évidemment de la DGS qui elle
aussi où les agents de la DRN la
Direction du renseignement militaire le
légionnaire lui s'il est passé de
l'autre côté comme disait effectivement
monsieur pour
peut-être passer de l'autre côté de la
frontière pour aller aider sa famille
alors qu'il n'en a pas le droit puisque
le général père légion comme on
l'appelle à bien spécifier les les
choses c'est une permission
exceptionnelle pour récupérer sa famille
hors de la frontière
ukrainienne mais il y a le téléphone
portable vous avez le tendance à mettre
le téléphone et à montrer voilà vos
alors on va aller appeler ça des amis
sur votre votre question
c'est très clairement c'est pas nous
qu'on peut répondre de ça et je serai
très étonné ce qu'on peut dire et ça
c'est sûr c'est qu'elle est légère qui
participent en Pologne ou ailleurs à la
formation ou à de l'interprétariat
j'espère que je me trompe pas en disant
le mot pour faciliter la formation des
Ukrainiens mais aller faire du
renseignement même si on a des crabes
chez nous d'abord c'est pas à moi de
répondre à ça ni mais sur le travail
c'est pas ça m'étonnerait fort ça sera
le mot de la fin merci un grand merci
vraiment à tous les trois trois d'avoir
parlé de ce corps d'élite qui est la
Légion étrangère qui ne ressemble on l'a
bien compris avec vos propos à aucun
autre corps d'armée vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc à mon avis
elle va être nombreux je compte
d'ailleurs sur vous pour réagir à ce que
ce qu'on sait ces réactions rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]